travis i'm wondering if we can talk
about the levels of dimension
in a character so if we could talk about
what a three-dimensional character looks
like
and then one that's two-dimensional and
finally just a one-dimensional character
so how does one look flat versus a fully
fleshed out maybe three-dimensional
character i'm not sure how to do 2d
that's a
interesting concept 1d in 3d makes sense
to me 2d i
created that yeah okay
[Laughter]
uh like this one i guess 2d is telling
me a piece of paper so there's
that um so one
so a single dimensional character
somebody was just kind of there
to facilitate the plot um
like they're there to basically just be
a moving piece along the way
um where they're just an anchor for the
story
um they're usually somebody who the
story is happening too and they're not
really making any choices they're just
kind of being pushed along by
all the stuff that's occurring around
them um a three-dimensional character is
more like a real human being who makes
choices and some of those choices are
good and some of those choices are bad
um there's somebody who actually at
least makes decisions about the things
you know they're not somebody who is
being
pushed along by like if the killer's
running after them they're not
just going upstairs because that's where
the story needs to take place you know
there's somebody who might
fight back against the the bad guy you
know um
or somebody who may go and cower in a
closet somewhere you know it's very
character specific um you know somebody
who
may have a different experience you know
like
uh have like the exact same story if you
have the main character
be a hairdresser they're gonna make way
different decisions than
a character who's an fbi agent and that
would be a three-dimensional
character because they're all the
choices of of what they're doing
has to do with their experiences 1d
character would be somebody who we don't
if it was an fbi agent or a
beauty salon person it doesn't matter
because they're just going where the
story's going you know so
um yeah that's my best again 2d is a
piece of paper i don't know what to do
with that for a character
or maybe they're an fbi agent that has a
cover
as a hair salon and then these women can
find all these
these things and they're like oh and
then they get these tips
[Laughter]
are there different tests though that
you when you look at the characters that
you're writing and you say you know what
this is too
this is too one-dimensional right here
um
well i i try to come up with so i
i'm i'm personally more of a plot
writer than a character writer but even
in having a plot you need the characters
to make sense
i'm not going to make i still need to
find the
character to have in this place like if
i want an alien invasion story
i am not going to write a character that
could be
anything just because all i care about
is the cool explosions of having an
alien invasion happen
and so i have i need to find i need to
find characters that are gonna
make cool decisions that are cinematic
based on what's happening to them
so if i want something that's gonna be
like high impact action where like the
good guy is fighting back i might have a
soldier as as the league character
and they're gonna make way different
decisions than like just the general
public is you know so they're gonna
be helping other people get out of the
situation they're gonna be fighting back
against the aliens they're gonna be
plotting and scheming and coming up with
whatever they can to survive
help others survive and defeat the bad
guy whereas if i want something that's
just a terror driven
thing where we are like on the edge of
our seats of oh my god
when is this person going to die i might
have just a regular joe schmoe
who has no experience they're just
looking out for themself
maybe not helping other people unless
they can't help it um
you know who's going to be cowering in
their car and they
are probably going to die at any point
where so
at that point it's like oh when is this
person going to die versus the soldier
oh when is he going to beat the aliens
you know and because it's the same setup
because it's a different character it's
the same it's a completely different
story
now um so it's kind of one of those
things of like okay if i
i want this story to be about a specific
to go a certain route
i need to find the character that helps
that route along
and isn't just some random person you
know based on what the experiences are
and even then my story because again i'm
outlining right so
in the outline i'm coming up with okay
what character would best facilitate now
i have to think
well what decisions is this character
going to make and how does that change
the rest of the plot that
i originally had in mind and so going
from my initial
like one sentence thing that i write my
idea book may be a completely different
animal now that i have
the character for it um
[Music]
yes with your script if we go back to
which you said was loosely based on you
or it was really yours right
it was a loosely based thing like their
thing the character was going through
the same
stuff that i was going through um
sometimes a little more dramatic than
what my own stuff was uh and a
vastly different outcome from what my
personal experience was
uh but yeah like that script was loosely
based on the the situation i was in
do you feel that that character was
three-dimensional or do you feel like
the writing i feel like that character
was
me uh in a sense and me kind of living
out
my own fantasy of how i like what i feel
like i should have done
the first two-thirds of that script was
the character was as weak as i was in
this situation
um where it was he was letting the stuff
happen to him and not really fighting
back
and i felt like if the stuff i was
writing was basically like
how i wanted to get out of that
situation but i in real life i was just
too like weak to do it like i knew what
needed to be done i just couldn't
convince myself to actually do it so i
had the character who had the same
situation as me and he was just as weak
as i was
until he finally found the strength to
push forward and do what needed to be
done
uh and even then like once i wrote that
point that was when i was able to like
end that scenario in my own life um
it was it was a i was in an abusive
relationship as is what that was and
so you know like it was almost like a
reverse
lifetime movie you know there's a lot of
life that movies where like you've got
the
the woman who's being beaten by the man
and stuff you know and following her
trail
so it was the guy being beaten by his
wife at the time you know and so
i you know in real life like i couldn't
get myself to get out of that situation
oh i don't want to cry i'm sorry oh i'm
sorry oh i feel bad now
no um so like i knew that i needed to
get out of the situation but i just
couldn't get myself to do it you know
because i i was like low self-esteem at
the time so i felt like i couldn't do
any better
than than that and uh so
in the writing he you know rose above it
i'm sorry oh
okay so he in the story you know like
found the power that i couldn't
basically and and rose above it and then
had like a much much different ending
obviously than than just
leaving leaving it because i wanted to
be like kind of cinematic too so there
was like some
thrillery stuff thrown into the third
act of that um that obviously never
happened in real life but
it was the same situation the same sort
of feelings and it was kind of like so
that's why was it like therapy for me
yeah to get out of it okay
you